[Musik]
hallo zusammen wir machen heute wieder
mal ein apfelrezept ich muss sagen
mittlerweile habe ich ein ganzes Lexikon
voll apfelrezept auf meinem Kanal und
wir machen heute einen Apple crumble
cake also eine Apple crumble Torten ein
Torte ist nicht Kuchen weil Torte ist ja
wenn noch eine Creme dazwischen ist wir
machen es richtig knusprig aber auch mit
einem Rührteig dabei und ich habe auch
ein Apple crumble Rezept auf meinem
Kanal liebe ich das könnt ihr euch auch
mal ansehen nachdem ihr das Rezept
angeschaut habt und ich lege direkt los
alle ganz genauen Mengenangaben stehen
wie immer unten in der
Mehl ist drin erstmal die trockenen
Zutaten ich habe jetzt zwei Zuckersorten
einmal weißen und einmal braunen der
braune schmeckt einfach ein bisschen
karamelliger dann darf Zimt niemals
fehlen gerade jetzt zu Jahreszeit und
anschließend kommt die flüssige Zutat
rein oder die Zutaten weil ich habe hier
einmal zerlassene Butter bei geringer
Backzeit in der Mikrowelle schmelzen und
Vanille extra gebe ich noch dazu es
verrühre ich einmal vorab und dann mit
den Händen einfach zu crumbled also zu
Streuseln verkneten dann machen wir
weiter mit dem Rührteig
[Musik]
so die crumbles sind ready wir machen
weiter mit unserem Rührteig der geht
auch echt schnell damit einfach den
gleichen Teigschaber spare ich mir
nämlich das Geschirr sondern kommt jetzt
zimmerwarme Butter ich habe es vergessen
aus dem Kühlschrank zu nehmen da habe
ich ganz kurz in die Mikrowelle getan
also Zimmer warme Butter kommt in die
Maschine Zucker kommt mit dazu
Vanilleextrakt und eine gute Prise Salz
falls euch fragt warum immer Prise Salz
ach so Zucker kommt rein ähm die hebt
einfach noch mal den süßen Geschmack und
macht einfach noch mal ein bisschen rund
so und das ganze lasse ich dann für ca 3
Minuten lang richtig schön hell cremig
schlagen und dann geht's weiter
[Musik]
ich habe jetzt noch das Ei und Schmand
mit rein gerührt nur so lange bis es
sich verbindet und jetzt kommen die
trockenen Zutaten rein also mehl und
Backpulver und das Ganze einmal kurz
reinschieben und dann nur so kurz wie
notwendig verrühren dann ist nämlich
auch der zweite Part fertig und als
nächstes schälen wir nur noch die Äpfel
[Musik]
so ich stehe schon mal zwei Äpfel nehmt
bei dem Rezept generell bei süßen
apfelrezepten immer gerne säuerliche
Äpfel steht immer dran im Supermarkt ist
oder Kaufland steht immer dran ob es
dann säuerlich ist oder süß und
säuerlich passt halt einfach besser bei
süßen Rezepten was den Geschmack einfach
rund macht genauso wie die Prise Salz
sind süßen Rezepten und ich muss sagen
ich lasse mir nicht jedes Jahr voll
viele apfelrezepte einfallen und voll
viele Fragen auch dann irgendwann gibt's
doch gar keine Rezepte mehr also
irgendwann hast du doch keine mehr oder
und das ist bei apfelrezepten ist es gar
nicht so ich kann mir immer wieder neue
apfelrezepte einfallen lassen und ich
habe eine Playlist mit so so vielen
apfelrezepten klickt euch da gerne mal
durch
was ich aber ganz lustig finde ist was
ich nicht habe in meiner Küche und ich
habe echt alles was du sinnvoll ist ist
so ein Apfel Entkerner den habe ich gar
nicht hast du eine Sache
ich habe einfach kein apfelentferner ich
mache das immer einfach ich schneide mit
dem Messer drumherum was habt ihr denn
so nicht was jeder hat schreibt mir das
mal in die Kommentare und ich sehe in
der Zwischenzeit die Äpfel schön und
schneide sie dann anschließend so ein
relativ kleines Stückchen
[Musik]
zu den Äpfeln habe ich jetzt noch ein
bisschen Zimt und ein bisschen Zucker
gegeben und ordentlich geschält und
jetzt habe ich meine 20 cm Springform da
gebe ich jetzt ein Backpapier drunter
eigentlich ist sehr gut beschichtet und
ihr braucht es nicht aber ich werde die
wahrscheinlich gleich noch mal mitnehmen
die Torte und so habe ich dann einfach
kann ich es ganz schnell rüber
transferieren in meine
tortentransportbox so da gebe ich jetzt
zuallererst den Boden also diesen
Rührteig rein nicht alles sondern nur
die Hälfte denn wir Schichten das ganze
jetzt dann kommt die Hälfte von den
Streuseln eine erst gebe ich die Äpfel
dazu dann die Streusel und dann
wiederhole ich das ganze noch mal also
zweimal kommt jede Schicht mit rein und
dann kommt in den Backofen schon mal
vorheizen auf 180 Grad Ober und
Unterhitze und dann backen wir das Ganze
für ca eine Dreiviertelstunde
[Musik]
so ich bin jetzt gerade bei der zweiten
Schicht muss schon sagen das sieht schon
echt pervers aus das sieht schon richtig
geil aus und ein Tipp von mir immer wenn
ihr so Untergründe habt wo es halt
schwierig ist es zu verstreichen jetzt
haben wir halt die crumbles und das ist
keine gerade kein gerade Untergrund dann
immer in klecksen verteilen weil dann
habt ihr schon mal überall großflächig
was verteilt und könnt dann einfach nur
noch so ganz grob alles verstreichen
dann kommen noch die restlichen Äpfel
und die restlichen crumbles dazu und ich
muss sagen es riecht jetzt schon mega
gut hier wenn es erst im Ofen ist dann
eigentlich müsste es so ein Raum gibt so
ein Raumduft Apfelkuchen Raumduft falls
ja bin die erste die mir das bestellt
gibt's das
Kerzen muss ich sagen also wenn ihr
irgendwas kennt und dann sehen könnt
dann schreibt es mal in die Kommentare
[Musik]
ja ich habe mir jetzt einfach mal ein
anderes Oberteil angezogen daher nicht
wundern das passiert wenn man sich den
ganzen Kaffee auf den Oberteil schüttet
aber nichtsdestotrotz habe ich hier ein
richtig genialen Apfelkuchen der riecht
extrem gut Leute oh richtig ich freue
mich richtig den äh zu genießen der ist
jetzt nur noch laufarm aber ich kann
hier schon mal einmal das ist mal mein
Magic Moment einmal springt vom Rand
entfernen ist das nicht ist perfekt
einfach perfekt ich habe jetzt hier noch
ein bisschen Puderzucker und dann gebe
ich Zitronensaft rein ich habe
eigentlich immer frische Zitrone da das
ist aber meine Neuentdeckung denn so
kann ich auch wenn ich mal so wie heute
keine frische Zitronen da habe das kann
man auch so praktisch dosieren einfach
hiermit in den Puderzucker rein so viel
bis ihr einfach so einen schönen Guss
habt und dann habt ihr auch noch mal so
ein zitronigen Pepp einfach auf eurem
Kuchen aber wenn ihr sagt ihr mögt das
nicht ihr möchtet lieber süß könnt ihr
statt das Zitronensaft auch z.B
Apfelsaft nehmen das geht auch oder
Orangensaft generell einfach
irgendwelche Säfte die ihr da habt
[Musik]
Jessica hallo für immer und natürlich
der Hamza und probiert gerne günstig den
gerne in die Hand ich habe den schon in
Stücke zurecht geschnitten einfach
einfach reinbeißen und ehrlich sind
von Dir
los boah das riecht einfach eine
Weihnachten im Winter Zimt
ja gut gutes Gespür
streuselig Vanille ja
mega lecker ist lecker oder
Weihnachtsmann
es wird heiß mega geil auch von der Süße
schmeckt perfekt so dann habt noch einen
wunderschönen Tag und bis zum nächsten
Mal tschüss
[Musik]